esta es mi primera votación en una
elección presidencial y aunque hay
desacuerdos en mi familia sobre a quien
votar especialmente con mi abuelo que es
un ferviente republicano voy a tener mi
propia lección
abuelo
no no
revela esto
jose manuel llegó de cuba en 1980 junto
a su esposa sus hijos y sus padres
empezó una nueva vida en florida
trabajando como fotógrafo y tratando de
olvidar los estragos del castrismo una
época confiesa que está reviviendo ahora
con la situación política en eeuu y
últimamente el partido demócrata se ha
ido completamente a la izquierda está
contra todas las libertades y entiendo
que de ser gobierno va a ser todo lo
posible por destruir esas libertades
tron aunque sea compro bercial
y en que no sea quizás el mejor
candidato es representa mayormente mi
manera de pensar
pero no comunismo formación en cambio su
nieta cree que haber vivido siempre en
el país norteamericano le ha permitido
tener una visión mucho más liberal que
la de sus antecesores y considera que
trump ha ayudado a incrementar la
división entre la población la edad y la
vaina y ahora en enero
escrito by the wind
creo que ahora estamos en medio de un
debate entre hechos y noticias falsas
hay demasiado odio en este país y creo
que joe biden es la opción que no va a
permitir más odio en este país
gates en descanso un abuelo conservador
y su nieta una ferviente demócrata
una situación que acostumbra pasar en
muchos lugares del exilio cubano en
estados unidos yo voy a votar pero yo
voy a votar por don otro
cada vez más se está dando una tendencia
en la población cubanoamericana a
aquellos que llegaron hace varias
décadas escapando de la dictadura de
fidel castro no quieren oír ni hablar de
las opciones de izquierda pero sus
descendientes aunque se han criado con
los mismos valores tienen otras
preferencias políticas que los muchachos
en el mundo de hoy se pasan un 70% del
tiempo fuera del núcleo familiar la
familia y esto no es una casualidad cada
vez va mas victimizada cada vez tienen
menos poder sobre esos vástagos florida
es un estado pendular las encuestas son
incapaces de determinar qué partido
recibirá mayor apoyo el voto latino es
determinante y los jóvenes podrían
acabar inclinando la balanza hacia un
lado u otro
el debate entre cubanos también se
traslada a este restaurante que es el
punto de reunión del exilio un 70 por
ciento votaría por donald trump la
discusión política entre demócratas y
republicanos y es algo habitual la
liberalización de la libertad de empresa
es desde luego sólo que queremos por
pero también queremos prosperidad
económica pero eso lo que te ha traído
otro queremos proponer cuando obama
tuvimos la debacle de hipotecas y no
[Música]
empezó con obama y terminó como el
último el primer paquete de ayuda fueron
700 mil millones 150 mil millones de él
una brecha generacional como la que se
da en la comunidad cubana empieza a
brotar entre los venezolanos otro
segmento de población que
tradicionalmente también vota
republicano a la papel
te cuento que ya me llegó la tarjeta de
votación
porque por trump no
laura lleva 13 años viviendo en eeuu
llegó de caracas será la primera vez que
voten unas elecciones y también lo hará
por una opción distinta a su familia se
vea una brecha generacional entre padres
e hijos de hecho eso sucede en mi casa
mis papás son pro trump y yo soy
provider
la gente que es por trump tiende a
pensar que él va a ser el salvador de
venezuela pero la verdad yo no lo creo
creo que bardem es una mejor opción y no
creo que sea un socialista y un peligro
para venezuela como lo pintan
una tendencia como la de laura y su
familia se podría generalizar en poco
tiempo estudios señalan que ahora siete
de cada diez venezolanos votan por trump
por supuesto que esos cambios que se dan
en los cubanos lógicamente de la misma
manera se están dando los venezolanos y
vas a ver que cada vez más esos
venezolanos que se van creando aquí o
que son hijos de venezolanos que nacen
aquí crecen aquí estudian aquí se forman
aquí van a pensar muy distintos
chelsea como no comparto enteramente en
tus opiniones pero como familia las
entiendo y podemos seguir teniendo
opiniones diferentes y seguir siendo
familia a pesar de las diferencias
políticas ellos coinciden en que eeuu es
una tierra de libertad que cada uno
puede expresar sus ideas sin miedo a
represalias y así ejercerán su voto el 3
de noviembre